l'argonaute c'est le nouveau complexe
sportif et culturel du quartier de
l'argonne à roland il a ouvert en
septembre 2017 et on y pratique une
quarantaine de disciplines le cercle
michelez a déménagé ses poids et
haltères pour l'argonaute après deux
décennies passées au centre d'orléans
les 600 adhérents n'ont pas tout suivi
mais le club a déjà glané de nouveaux
adeptes dans la métropole comme yacine
habitants h et si je fais du foot et
j'aimerais me progressé en muscles pour
avoir plus de lait physique sur le
terrain cherche pas du volume cherche
plutôt la puissance au niveau des fautes
christine elle a 68 ans est en charge de
l'haltéro santé une discipline très
prisée des femmes pour le maintien du
dos et ce n'est pas le déménagement du
club qui a mis un frein à sa forme
olympique où nous aime bien ce quartier
on a une super
une super salle qui est tout neuf
c'était notre ancienne salle c'est une
salle mythique c'était la salle rigolo
mais elles étaient trop trop anciennes
aurait fallu faire pleins pleins de
réaménagement ici à l'argonaute
l'éloignement du centre ville et plus
pensé par des conditions d'exercice
optimale de l'haltérophilie le matin
elle s'est même que rue pasteur est par
contre les locaux sont beaucoup plus
neuf et géographiquement on est beaucoup
mieux placé que les jeunes qui sont ici
l'ensemble des jeunes c'est que des gens
qu'on a de l'argent donc on à la salle
et on a triplé et même quadruplé le
l'effectif jaune juste en étant grâce à
la reine
l'objectif pour le cercle michelin c'est
de reprendre sa place sur le podium des
trois premiers clubs d'haltérophilie de
l'hexagone une ambition portée par le
champion de france master 2018 philippe
mot car pour qui la proximité avec les
autres associations de l'argonaute
s'avère être plus on avait un peu peur
aussi cette appréhension de partager les
locaux avec d'autres clubs sportifs ou
autres
et puis finalement non à la cua la
cohabitation se passe très très bien au
contraire on se croise on discute un peu
on fait connaissance et puis nous au
niveau du sport ça nous permet aussi de
pouvoir connaître d'autres personnes et
de mélange et diversifiée des choses pas